[Music]
during the second now
[Music]
block by Durant his fifth protection of
the game
[Applause]
Oh
there's a dude with 35 and white getting
it done defensively and then offense
rates taken over the final
to harass hurry hurry off the trailer
layout off the class
razzle dazzle at its best
: state Steph Curry entertaining the
warrior fans to once again whooping a
spectacular play the ball head handling
wizardry
James drives down
[Applause]
and calves for what a rejection from
draymond Green his fourth block of the
game what a play by draymond Green again
coming from the weak side sensing the
Brawn James not on my watch
outstanding effort big addala pushing
Wario's making a statement and not going
anywhere forcing the turnover andre
iguodala in transition gettin Higgy with
it spectacular job of attacking the best
way in the world
[Applause]
the ramp LOB's it up the key crumbs to
town
[Music]
she loved rotating Lake buggy to the rim
dunks it over I call that spreading love
what a weapon that is three-on-two Tory
puts up the three Celia and the foul and
the bestest is healing with the slam and
it's a 13-point lead and what a run in
finish by Festus Ezeli shot clock at
five
Kevin Durant way outside delivers Kevin
Durant from downtown it's a six-point
game a dazzling display from Kevin
Durant 43 points no fouls to get for
Cleveland ahead to curry curry sets
fires puts it up curry from way downtown
and the first half comes to it in in
dramatic fashion
[Applause]
Green pass too low victory recovers shot
clock winding down
so he's gonna have to put it up launches
it up shot clock we max it down
Steph Curry with the shot clock expiring
[Applause]
double one of those parking lot through
he's from curry how sick is this shot
Steph Curry Hanlon recognized the clock
to Quinlan down it actually looked
beautiful in the end a good job by
Shumpert
to avoid the foul Lennox concedes it off
Livingston
beautiful finish and probably got fouled
she got power what up at you boy Adam
left coach you like that content I know
you like that content hit subscribe for
more of it from Bleacher Report